Welcome back, so now we will talk about adaptation, something which is extremely important for
transfer learning, so in this case we will look into different technical aspects of adaptation,
the objective would be to take the source model, pretend model and we try to see how
we can adopt this particular model to the target task that we have, so we will see different
sorts of challenges and then how we can like you know use some methodologies to tackle
some of these problems and so on so forth, so the question is how to adapt, you know
it is all about taking one particular model, applying to a new task, so there are several
things that we have to keep in mind, first of all the architectural modifications, you
know now again stepping back for a while, what we are trying to achieve in this case,
we have a pre-trained model, existing model and we would like to make some changes to
the model for a new task without retraining for this particular task from scratch, because
we have limited data for the target task, we might have computational burden, computational
limitations and so on so forth, so the question is how much we should change to the pre-trained
model architectures for adaptation and there are various degrees of changes, change only
one layer, two layer, three layer, all sorts of things and we will see different kinds
of modifications for this adaptation.
Second thing is optimization schemes, now it is not only that you know the architectural
modification will give you all the necessary things, you need to also look into the optimization
schemes to deal with this little bit of extra training that you need in order to adapt to
the new task, so which ways to train during adaptation, what schedule you should follow,
what should set the learning rate and all sorts of things and third, can we use more
signals for example, the multitasking architectures, can we use signals from multiple tasks simultaneously
or you can ensemble things from different places and so on so forth, so these are some
of these things that we basically need to look into when we are trying to do adaptation.
Now as a programmer and as a designer, the adaptation is something extremely critical
for the deep learning, the pre-training and deep learning models.
So let us look into the architectural changes, what we can do because often and almost always
we have to do the architectural changes because we take one existing model, we make some changes
and we apply to a new task.
So broadly we achieve these things in two ways, number one we keep the pre-trained model
internals unchanged, we do not even touch upon the internals, what we do, we do a very
shallow thing like we add some classifier on top for example, if your objective is to
do image classification and you already have say pre-trained image vectors, then you simply
add one classification layer on top like polyconnected layer, softmax layer and so on so forth.
So you just add classifier on the top embedding at the bottom, use outputs as features and
so on so forth, so without changing the internal structure of this model, the model remains
same as is only few changes here and there.
The second thing is basically modifying the pre-trained model internal architecture and
that is something little bit more intricate than the previous one and like the situation
where this thing needs to be done is basically that if the task that we are dealing with
is very different from what we already had, this whole task.
So in a situation like this we may need to like initialize the encoder decoder slightly
different way, we may need to play with the encoder architectures and so on so forth.
We may need to add some adapters, special kind of things and so on and we will see in
a moment how you can do all of this thing.
So this is the first example of keeping your model architecture unchanged almost.
You just do little bit of very shallow processing on top of the existing model.
So what we do in this case, we simply remove the pre-training task head.
So if the architect is something like this, this is for example the original architecture,
so what we do is simply go and remove this particular one and we simply add for example
as one more layer something like this here.
So if there are four classes, we simply go and add and this is a fully connected layer
or maybe it could be a softmax layer something like this.
So you take out topmost layer, assuming that this particular task is for say image classification
and you have to do some kind of image segmentation or something like that.
We take out the layer for image classification, we add one more layer suitable for image segmentation
and simply get things done.
So in language model for example what we do, we basically add a particular layer depending
upon the task that we are dealing with whether this is a process of tagging, whether classification
and other things and so on and so forth.
In a sense that we don't touch upon the other layers only we remove the top one and then
make the changes.
And this is something actually pretty common, comparatively very light weight and very easy
to do in programming as well.
Here we can add target specific layers on top or the bottom of the piton layer is also
you can be added in the top layer or the bottom layer specific to the particular target.
Again we are not going to change the internals of this particular architecture.
The architecture remains the same, only the top or the bottom layers can be changed depending
upon the task that we are dealing with.
So often what we add, we add basically a single linear layer on top of the piton model and
again retrain this particular model with the little bit of data that we have for the target
task.
So another one is basically more complex tasks for example we have to do, we can use the separate
models for input, for output and so on and so forth.
And this kind of architecture is extremely useful when we have to basically do the interaction
between different tasks and the embeddings are not available beforehand and so on and
so forth.
So something like this.
So in a situation like this what we can do, we can basically use the multiple inputs coming
from different possible signals and basically we can concatenate all of the signals to a
single vector and simply pass it along to the corresponding architectures.
Once again we are not changing these architectures in any way, we are simply using these input
signals or changing this output layer just to adapt to the corresponding target task
that we are dealing with.
Now the more challenging thing is basically modifying the model internals.
In the previous case very little changes like either you change little bit in the input layer
or you change little bit of the output layer and so on so forth.
So in this case we would like to play with the changes in the model internals.
The structure will go through numerous changes and we have to do little bit more processing.
So this is required when the target task is structurally very different from the source
task because we have taken the model from the source task to different trying to apply
to a target task so if they are structurally very different the same architecture might
not work very well.
So in a situation like this we have to change the structure of this model some internals.
So, for example, you pretend to the single input sequence but you are trying to adapt
to a task with several input sequences for example.
Say your objective was sentence classification, you are applying this for next sentence prediction
tasks.
So typical approach that we follow in this case, we pretend the model's weight to initialize
as much as possible of a structurally different target task model.
So whatever weight we had in the original model we will use that and then basically on top
of this we are going to retrain this model based on the target data that we have.
So often what we do is basically use following your language models to initialize encoder
and decoder parameters for machine translation.
So if our objective is to do machine translation for example, we can basically learn or basically
lend the weights from the encoders and decoders and then straightaway apply for the machine
translation task.
So this is something that basically we could do here and there can change a lot of changes
in this model architectures.
Now for task specific modifications, we need to basically do, we need to add some capabilities.
So we provide the pretend models with capabilities and this such that they are useful for the
target tasks.
So one of the common thing for example we do in say that language processing or in vision
models and so on and so forth adding skip connections, residual connections or attentions
and so on and so forth.
So in the simpler case when we are not modifying these architectures, we are not adding anything
like that.
We are simply adding one more extra layer on top of it say fully connected layer, soft
back layer and so on and so forth.
No skip connection, no residual connection, no attention, nothing like that.
But in this case because the target task is more demanding, structurally different than
the source task, we are going to add say for example NLP, the attention layers or say in
image we can use the residual connections like in ResNet and so on and so forth.
So one of the major goals in adaptation that we must use the least number of parameters
because the amount of data that we have is lesser compared to what we should have and
therefore the number of parameter that we should use in a situation like this should
be lesser than the original model.
So we basically have to do less parameter tuning because this is anyway going to be fine tuning
on sitting on top of this original model.
So it is very useful given the increasing size of this model parameters and we generally
add the bottleneck modules to achieve this called adapters.
Adapter is typically a connecting component between different layers of the pretend models.
So one of these adapters could be basically additional attention layer or it could be
say for example the skip connection between two layers and so on and so forth.
So this picture is something like this that there are different kinds of layers.
So the A1 adapter is basically connecting this particular layer if I number this in
this way 3 and 4.
So this A1 is basically connecting 1 to 2, specific kind of adapter which will fulfill
to some extent of course cannot fully fulfill the demand that we are having for the target
task to some extent can fulfill the requirement and the limitations of this pretend model.
Then A2 is connecting these two layers adapter.
This is connecting these two layers and adapter and so on so forth.
So as I mentioned the adapters could be something like the residual connections or the attentions
and so on so forth.
So the broad objective of the adapters basically is to fine tune this features little more given
the nature of the task that we are dealing with.
If the task is complex we require more fine tuning and therefore we have to be very careful.
So as I mentioned the common thing that we do is residual connections in parallel to
an existing layer so we can add residual connections between two different layers and so on.
So often we do like we basically interleave these adapters in between different layers
so that they can learn better representations from different layers.
And so this could be different for example when this is a vision task we could add the
convolutional kind of things.
When you are dealing with NLP tasks we can add the self attention layers and so on so
forth because the goals are different and therefore the adapters that we basically play
with are different.
So this is one good reference where they have used adapters to adapt these new models to
the new tasks and achieved good performance even with the limited amount of data on the
target domain.
Next important component is weight update schedule.
Now let us step back for a moment and try to think about on which set of we are standing
so far.
So we have original model, pretend model, we made some changes here and there maybe
the simple changes like at top or at bottom or maybe like the model internals and so on
so forth.
So as you know a typical deep learning model is nothing but a collection of parameters
that means the weights and biases.
So the moment you make any changes to the model we have to learn this new weights accordingly
as nicely as possible.
So because somewhere we are making some changes, somewhere things are constant.
So what strategies we should take to update the weights and that is a very critical thing
in deep learning pre-training as deep learning like the domain adaptation or this transfer
learning and deep learning.
So the question is we have to update weights for sure but in which order this is something
extremely critical and how should we do that?
There could be many strategies to do that.
So in which order we should do it and how should we do that?
But the main goal that we have to keep in mind is that that in doing so we must not
overwrite the information already there in the pre-trained models because the pre-trained
models giving us the necessary background and the backbone on which we will be standing.
Now if by adding new things we are going to change the weights to a great deal then the
models are going to be changed a lot.
So the original information will be lost and therefore this seriously questions the capabilities
of this model, generalizations of this model on the new data and so on and so forth.
So while for sure we have to change the weights we have to keep in mind that we are not going
to overwrite the existing information.
So common approach for weight update is basically from top to bottom.
So you have multiple layers for example 1, 2, 3, 4 and every layer have some weights.
So I consider this w1, this is w2, w3 and so on so forth.
So the common approach that we follow very cost effective, easy to implement and all
sorts of things is basically update from top to bottom.
So you progressively in time we simply freeze the other layers, the weights in the other
layers and simply update a particular layer one at a time from top to bottom that is very
common.
For example when I am trying to change this particular weight w3, w2 and w1 they will
remain constant.
I am not going to do anything on this.
Then once I am done with w3 I achieved a good performance based on the data that I have
in the target domain then I will basically freeze this one then I will go to the w2,
make some changes while keeping other things frozen and then simply proceed.
The other thing is basically progressively in intensity.
So the learning rate is something is extremely critical for good optimization for getting
the right objective for speeding up this model and so on so forth.
Now the question is how we should vary the learning rates?
What should the schedule for varying the learning rates?
And then progressively versus the pre-tent model the regularization stuff.
How we can basically make the model little regularized so that we do not lose any information
that we already had.
So in weight freezing what we do and that is the main intuition which drives the weight
freezing is that we train all layers on data with different distribution and tasks like
if we try to do that may lead to instability and poor solutions.
There is a main concern that we have that we simultaneously try to learn all the layers
and so on so forth may dismantle the entire thing that we have learnt because the data
that we are dealing with very small in quantity and we cannot do very much.
So then why not take this particular approach where we are not going to dismantle everything
simultaneously.
We simply take one at a time, make the changes, freeze it and then take the others.
That is the more or less this idea.
So we take individual layers, we adapt it to the new task, see how they are performing
on the new task and simply freeze it and then proceed.
So this something is called the layer wise training which is very old technique invented
by one of the pioneers of deep learning back in 2006 and that is still widely used in the
transfer learning based on the deep learning models.
There are other approaches, very common approaches like chain thaw, gradual unfreezing, sequential
unfreezing and so on so forth.
So here what we do, freezing all but the top layer.
So I freeze all the layers except the top layer and then simply go and train it because
this only one layer I am going to make changes to.
So extremely fast, requires little data and so on so forth.
But optimization wise is probably not the right thing to do, is probably going to sacrifice
this accuracy little bit, it may lose the generalizability of this model and so on so
forth but is very cost effective and also requires lesser amount of data.
The second approach is called the chain thaw.
So in this case we no longer dealing with only a single layer, we are dealing with multiple
layers but we train one layer at a time, we train a new layer something like this then
train one layer at a time then what we do basically something like this then we train
all layers.
So gradually we will basically increase this intensity of training.
When we basically added a new layer, we first train that then we have to make changes to
the other existing layers because no longer they are very well connected.
So we change, make changes to the layers one at a time and once this is done then we train
all layers.
Now one might be questioning that whether this is optimal thing to do, right?
Suddenly this is not an optimal thing to do but when you are done with the second step
training one layer at a time then you already have a good initial points and therefore standing
on top of these when you train on all layers the things become little faster.
The third approach is called gradual unfreezing.
So in this case we will unfreeze one layer after another, initially everything is present
we only unfreeze one layer after another.
In the previous case we are freezing all else but only one but in this case we are taking
the reverse approach, we will unfreeze one layer and then simply proceed make the changes
and simply move on.
So this is an example of like this gradual unfreezing one layer after the another one,
something like this we will do.
The final thing is called sequential unfreezing, now in all previous cases we are dealing with
the weights associated with the different layers and so on so forth.
But there are many hyper parameters that are extremely critical for models performance
and I do not know yet how to deal with them.
So in this case in the sequential unfreezing what we do we fine tune the additional parameters
for different epochs gradually.
So as you know in training what happens?
Training happens to multiple epochs, first epoch you take all data, you make changes,
second epoch you take other data, the same data but in a different sequence you make
changes and so on so forth.
So while we are basically proceeding epoch by epoch we would like to fine tune this additional
parameters to the hyper parameters, they are not model parameters like weights and biases
but they are extremely important parameters and we will try to basically control them
nicely so that they can do very good job on the target task.
So for example you can fine tune pretend parameters without embedding layers for several epochs
and then see what happens.
And you train all layers until convergence, something like this we could do gradually.
So in sequential unfreezing finally what we do we train all parameters jointly, once we
have done this sequentially after epoch by epoch finally we will train all parameters
jointly to achieve better results.
Now I must add in this is that that none of this approaches can guarantee the optimal
performance, they are good balance between the effectiveness and the computational efficiency
and the generalizability because you are operating on limited computing budget, we are operating
on lesser amount of data.
So all these the heuristics approaches that we have seen so far they can tackle some of
the limitations to some extent but they certainly are not full proof approaches and one needs
to basically adapt to the new tasks depending upon the performance.
So one simple guideline that one can follow is that you look at the loss functions how
they are basically behaving and so on so forth and then basically you can choose that which
layers are actually affecting more.
So you probably can focus on those layers which are affecting more, less on the layers
which are affecting less and so on so forth.
The another important thing is regularization because the setup we are operating on is something
like this that we have a pre-trained model which is trained on large volume of data and
we are trying to apply this model on new tasks sort of trying to adapt this particular model
in new tasks and we are going to basically make some changes here and there but at the
same time we are not we must not lose the original information.
So if we let the parameters change a lot then they can dismantle the original learning
that we had.
So in addition to all of the things that we have seen so far we also need to add a regularization
term so that the parameters in the new model or the learned parameter in the new models
they remain as close to as the original model.
So it is very popular L2 regularization that we apply in most of these learning models we
can apply.
So we simply add this particular term to the original objective function for the new task
and we of course need to control the hyperparameter associated with this particular expression.
So something like this is happening here.
So we have for example this original model that we are having here and then we adapt
to this particular new model something like that L1 prime, L2 prime, L1 prime and E prime
and so on and so forth okay and they will have their own sets of new parameters.
So the regularization term that we are dealing with is basically we will try to look into
the difference between the original model parameters of different layers and the new
model parameters of the new architecture that we are dealing with.
The third important thing and this is extremely critical because this can overshoot the good
optimal point often and can also speed up the training.
So scheduling the learning rate that's a very critical component in this not only in
the pre-training of the deep learning models or the transfer learning but this is also
very critical for training the normal model as well.
So what we like to do?
The main idea is that we would like to use lower learning rates to avoid overwriting existing
information because if you set a very big learning rate okay they can basically take
your model to some other point and as a result you know you can have the overwriting of existing
information that you had in the original model.
So to tackle this problem what we do basically do?
We take this approach is that in the lower layers typically we capture general information
in a standard deep net that's the general belief is that the lower layers will capture
general information and as you move up gradually they will modify the information or the features
specific to a particular task that we are dealing with okay.
So keeping in mind this observation what we do?
So early in training the new model still needs to adapt to the target distribution okay because
the new model that we have we have added few layers top or at the bottom we also probably
have modified the internals little bit for example adding new attention layer or adding
say skip connection and so on so forth so we need to basically train all these new parameters
okay.
So while we are very early in the training with respect to the new data or the target
data that we have we need to adapt the distribution nicely and then in the late in training the
model is close to convergence so we have to be little more careful in setting the learning
rate as well okay so these three observations basically have to keep in mind while we are
setting this thing.
So one of the very effective learning rate schedule for transfer learning based on the
deep learning is something like this that again it is driven by the observation that
lower layers capture general information so we would like to use lower learning rates
for lower layers.
So essentially what we do we use a particular scheme where the learning rates will be adapted
to a particular layer so alpha is a constant in this case and the alpha i is basically
associated with a particular layer and d to the power i d is a basically constant factor
and i is a layer so as you basically go up then it will basically you know modify this
particular learning rate with respect to the layer depth and it will set accordingly okay
as opposed to a fixed learning rate like alpha it will be different for different layers.
So these are basically some of the main I would say the strategies to deal with the
architectural changes when you make to adapt this new models to the new tasks.
Now one of the common things that we do often like this is something that not exactly related
to pre-training this can be done simultaneously as well as multitask learning okay.
So in the setup something like this happens like we simultaneously undertake multiple
tasks using a single network we do not want to use different networks for different tasks
but rather only one network for different tasks okay and what we like to avoid we like
to avoid having different like the models for different tasks okay because the general
assumption is that that if the network is big enough then at least the lower layers
can learn some common representations for tasks which share some commonality okay and
standing on those assumptions can I come up with some architectures which will have
lesser number of parameters which will require lesser number of data and so on so forth.
So there are broadly two basic forms of MTL is hard parameter sharing and soft parameter
sharing.
So in hard parameter sharing so the models basically share weights between different tasks
okay for example in this case so in this particular branch there is a common thread
you can see okay nothing specific to particular tasks okay you can think about these are basically
different blocks of individual models for example if you take transformer the transformer
blocks if you take residual network it could be residual blocks and something like that
very common but near the end of this network you can add two, three different branches
or three, four whatever the number depends on the number of tasks that you are dealing
with different branches okay which will basically do the task specific things and these blocks
will basically have different sets of parameters okay.
So this set is basically shared parameters and then only at the top level you have different
parameters for different tasks and we call this hard parameter sharing.
The second component or second very common approach that we follow is called soft parameter
sharing so instead what we have in this case we will have say for example separate threads
for separate tasks that we deal with so if you have three tasks we have separate threads
but at the same time these separate models will also exchange information between themselves
through the cross talks or cross links okay again they are different links they are all
parameterized so something like you have a separate weight say w1, w2 it is a weight
matrix and so on so forth 3, 4 and so on.
So the cross talks will have these parameters associated with them so they will exchange
the vectors so the representation learned in different blocks for the different tasks
okay so that they can share information between themselves.
So in vision one of the very popular architectures in MTL is called shared trunk okay so in this
case what happens is that just like this one of this thing that in a hard parameter sharing
we have seen in this case so all the entire thing there is a big trunk you know which
is basically very common and so you have to do end tasks at the end of it okay from a
particular image so image classification, image segmentation, object detection and all
sorts of things okay so I naturally I do not want to do many things okay increasing the
number of parameters in my model and so on so forth.
So again the assumption is that the shared trunk will produce generally enough information
which we can further fine tune to achieve our end goals several goals so all that basically
you have to do at end of it so this is the final representation okay this one and end
of it you can basically add this many branches number of the number of branches equals to
the number of tasks that you have and accordingly you can basically add some little heads which
will be responsible for basically you know serving your purpose.
Cross stitching is another approach in multitask learning so in this case what happens is that
you use separate network for each task okay if you obtain tasks you use separate network
but the input to each layer is basically a linear combination of output from the previous
layer of each network so as you can as you can see from this particular figure so this
is basically there are two tasks only we are dealing with task A and task B task A and
task B so because this particular network is responsible for task A this particular
network is responsible for task B and they have identical structure okay there is one
important constraint in this case in cross stitching and the parallel blocks in the network
for example this block and this block okay so the representation coming from the parallel
blocks okay will basically will be shared between these networks and through a linear
combination okay so these weights you can see the alpha basically the linear combination
of weights is coming from different blocks okay so linear combination will be done based
on the representation which are coming from the parallel blocks okay so it will never
happen something like this for example the information exchange will never happen something
like this okay only through this corresponding parallel blocks some okay something like this
and of course this particular model has many more parameters than a typical model that
we have seen like shared trunk and so on and so forth but if the tasks are very different
to each other for example in this case the cross stitching is a much better architecture
compared to the shared trunk approach because in that case we are assuming that they substantially
share the amount of features another approach is prediction distillation so in this case
what happens is that you know we again use lot of parameters in this particular model
so first we do predictions for each task and then these predictions are again combined
using a multimodal network to produce the final output okay so this is two level training
that we do okay first we basically apply one set of network then we use another network
common network for multimodal distillation then it will generate vectors and then we
basically fine tune this vector to produce this final output and I will end with this
particular architecture so this is the nlp application is very common so in this case
say for example you have architecture like transformer or bot okay something like this
we can have or you have can have any other architectures okay so they will produce common
representations for language okay nothing specific to particular task and then you can
take the corresponding parts from this particular network to produce different sorts of things
for example textual similarity relation extraction you would like to do some kind of inference
or reasoning named entity recognition and so on and so forth okay the only thing that
you need to be careful about is that while you are picking things from the pretend model
in this case you have to choose the right thing okay so one thing you probably notice
in this case here is that while we are doing textual similarity okay we are no longer using
all hidden vectors okay the CLS token is good enough in this case okay because CLS token
is the ultimate representation for the entire text that will be good enough but if we are
doing say for example sequence tagging like named entity recognition then it's probably
better to use all the information that we have so hidden vectors from different places
in the network so in that case we will basically combine all the hidden vectors that we have
in this particular network so depending upon the task one has to decide which portion of
the representation that you have learned from the basic model will be useful for this particular
task and on top of this you add the corresponding like this head for a specific task and optimize
it using these target data that we have okay so I will stop here so if you have any question
I can take up this questions okay so the question is why do we need transfer learning so as
I mentioned we do transfer learning primarily for two things number one is that when we
have lesser amount of data in the target task or target domain and second thing when we
have the computational constraint because training deep networks from scratch on a new
task will require both lot of computational power as well as a lot of annotated data so
when you lack this thing then transfer learning is a is a viable thing to do it won't give
you as much accuracy as you typically get when you try to learn a big models from scratch
but that's a better alternative when you have these constraints the second question is how
does the data distribution affect the quality of knowledge transfer so this is one of the
most critical thing and that actually makes and breaks the quality of output that you
get so often if the data distribution is very different from the one you had in the original
model okay you might have unstable model in the sense that that you might get good performance
on whatever little that that you have in the target domain but if the domain changes little
bit here and there the data changes little bit here and there that might affect a lot
so to tackle that one approach is basically to tackle this problem is basically adding
regularization term to this particular model so that you don't over feed too much to the
little data that you have for the target task third question is does data augmentation help
transfer learning so data augmentation indeed helps transfer learning because you already
have very little data for the target task so if you do data augmentation little bit
then it can have it can add little bit of variety to the target task and that in turn
help learn the model better and improve the generalization of this model why do we often
fine tune the deeper layers so as I mentioned repeatedly that we often fine tune the deeper
layers so reason is that that the initial layers or the layers like sitting at near
the embedding layers and so on so forth so they capture the general information so general
representations and as a result so they can be fine tuned or modified to serve different
other purposes okay so if we try to fine tune those layers then we basically lose the general
information and we have very little opportunity to get those information back in the top layers
so as a result we can basically pick out the relevant part from the vectors that we are
getting from the shallow layers and we can modify it depending upon the task that we
were dealing with next question is what is the relationship between the layer freezing
and the optimality of the objective function okay that's a very that's a very involved
question so you might recall that layer freezing is basically while we are trying to update
the weights we often we cannot do that like the entire network we cannot do that so we
do layer freezing okay so we are freezing a particular layer we won't let it change
okay and we are basically changing a particular other layer so naturally it does not give
you the optimal solution like the objective function may not achieve the right value at
the end of it but that's a viable alternative because the objective is to minimize the
computational cost and this is one way you can achieve this one so to summarize the whole
thing is that we cannot get the optimal solution for the objective function by layer freezing
but just to reduce the computational burden we adopt this particular strategy.
The next question is while fine-tuning a pre-tent model how do we schedule the learning rates
okay so as you know the learning rates are extremely critical component in optimization
so if they are big you may over shoot the destination if they are small it may take
lot of time okay so while you fine-tune the pre-tent models typically when you are starting
off we can keep the learning rates little high okay we can keep the learning rates for
the deeper layers little high and the low for the shallow layers simply because if we
set the learning rates to be very high for the shallow layers then basically we are going
to lose the general information that we have learned and as a result we may not recover
that while we are trying to fine-tune the deeper layers okay the next question is is
batch normalization helpful in transfer learning so batch normalization is a very important
regularization technique in transfer learning or rather in any deep learning so it is also
true for transfer learning as well so it does help because this basically helps regularize
this model better so when you are trying to adopt a model a changed model to a new data
they will also go through lot of changes the distribution of this output layers in intermediate
layers and so on and so forth and the batch normalization will regularize those changes
okay and as a result it will achieve better generalization okay the next question is since
data scarcity is a major issue in transfer learning why can't we use gain or generative
adversarial network to generate more data and train a model what is the potential downside
okay in fact the answer to the first question is if we do use gain to generate more data
this kind of data augmentation technique okay in a different way they do use that one so
yes this is a viable alternative to augment data using gain but the potential downside
is this that if the target data target data that we have have very little variety then
the gain will end up generating very similar kind of data okay so it will produce something
like rich gets richer kind of model as a result those who are present in the data will benefit
from it those who are not present are very less in numbers they will not benefit from
it so yes if the diversity of the data even in the original in the original the target
task is good enough then gain could be a very good approach otherwise that could be risky
thing to do.
Next question is can transfer learn models be attacked so as you know the attack is a
very common thing in deep learning models like people can basically attack a learn model
and get the original data even if you do not have the original data available okay so just
like other models transfer learn models can be also attacked okay people can actually
you know apply the attack methods to get back the data but it is less risky compared to
the original models because of the additional fine tuning that we have done okay so unlike
the original models where we basically know more or less how the models were trained and
so on so forth so attack methods can relatively easily get back the original data.
With the final and the last question what is the consequence of transferring based on
a pre-tent model trained on highly imbalanced data okay that is again a general problem
for any deep learning or any machine learning problem so if the pre-tent model was trained
on highly imbalanced data that means it tends to do very well on the majority of this data
and not so well on the rare data now if on the target domain or on the target tasks the
data is coming from for example the rare category okay the model might go through a lot of changes
because there is a mismatch between data distribution in the pre-tent model and in
the new domain okay so the parameter might change a great deal that has some consequences
in terms of losing the general information that we had in the original model okay so
these are the questions the pre-structured question that I had and I thank you all of
you for attending this and if you have any other question you can reach out to me through
my emails and I am happy to respond to your questions.